on ne le dira jamais assez la musique
c'est primordial et les effets le sound
design dans une vidéo ça fait on va dire
allez au moins 50% du rendu final c'est
hyper important
c'est pour ça qu'on va en parler
aujourd'hui vous et moi juste après
l'intro
[Musique]
et ça urge en arrière écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique moi
encore je suis ravi de vous retrouver
pendant les vacances pour une petite
vidéo un petit peu en sujets où on va
parler de musique et de vidéos parce que
souvent vous me demandez mais où est ce
que tu trouves des musiques et tout ça
tout ça on en parle aujourd'hui je vais
donc vous parler du site que j'utilise
depuis plus de deux ans 1 c'est-à-dire
art liste est pourquoi je ne vous en ai
pas parlé plus tôt
et bien tout simplement parce que je
suis totalement convaincu par ce site je
vous expliquer pourquoi
par la suite et que j'attendais tout
simplement qu'ils me proposent de faire
une vidéo sponsorisés parce que dans la
mesure où je savais que j'allais faire
cette vidéo forcément puisque je crois
dans le produit
je me suis dit y'a pas de raison que je
leur fasse de la pub sans contrepartie
donc cette vidéo elle est sponsorisée
par l'artiste mais elle est écrite
depuis bien avant qu'ils ne me propose
le sponsoring comme ça vous savez c'est
transparence c'est clair y'a pas de
soucis donc dans cette vidéo je vous
faire une petite présentation du site de
commandes' repères de comment on trouve
de la musique comment ces foutus et
pourquoi c'est bien foutu mais je vais
aussi vous expliquer pourquoi j'ai
choisi artistes et surtout quel est ce
gros gros gros plus pour les freelances
comme moi qui ai vraiment le truc qui
fait que je pars chez eux
systématiquement et que pour rien au
monde jean changerait pour le moment
mais ça ce sera en fin de vidéo et we
watched i'm toi même tu sais et pour la
petite histoire je n'ai pas activer la
monétisation sur cette vidéo puisque il
ya déjà du sponsoring donc pas de raison
plus que vous vous tapiez des pubs allez
cette fois ci c'est parti on y va on
plonge dans le site et on va regarder un
petit peu comment tout ça est fichu
alors quand on arrive sur arte liste on
retrouve basse nous repère de n'importe
quel site qui propose un petit peu la
même chose pour un abonnement annuel de
199 dollars se fait à peu près
l'équivalent en euros avec les taxes et
tout ça on a un accès illimité à tout un
catalogue de musique dans tous les
genres dans tous les styles et ses
musiques vous allez pouvoir les utiliser
pour vos vidéos pour votre chaîne
youtube pour vos clients mais ça on y
reviendra un petit peu après parce que
c'est là qu'est le la petite subtilité
super sympa alors déjà le premier truc
sympa avant même d'aller faire un tour
dans le site c'est qu'on peut écouter
les musiques sans forcément avoir de
compte
donc ça c'est déjà génial on n'est pas
obligé d'aller souscrire à un abonnement
même
dc pour pouvoir aller écouter le style
de musique essayer de voir s'il ya pas
des musiques qui nous intéresserait déjà
c'est pas mal pour elle vous faire une
idée gratuitement un petit peu du son
qui a dessus j'en profite juste à ce
moment de la vidéo aussi pour te dire
que si cette vidéo te plaît et que tu
peux en voir d'autres et ne rien rater
tu peux aussi t'abonner activer la
cloche tout ça tout ça au niveau des
classements on a plusieurs façon de
classer en a par type d'événement par
exemple si on fait du mariage si on fait
du corporate
si on fait du blog il ya déjà des
playlists en fait qui sont faites donc
là dessus c'est super pratique on peut
chercher aussi par ce style musical ou
pas rumeurs c'est à dire que si on veut
quelque chose de dramatique ou si on
veut quelque chose d'hyper joyeux on va
pouvoir aller chercher en fonction de ça
et on peut combiner les tags pour aller
trouver la chanson le morceau qui va
bien s'est mis à jour régulièrement il
ya tout le temps plein de nouveautés la
qualité des productions est vraiment
très très très très très très bonne ça
fait vraiment très très pro et bahreïn
pour ça c'est plutôt cool alors
récemment ils ont ajouté une partie
sound design sound effect qui est
payante
c'est le truc que je trouve un petit peu
dommage de ne pas l'avoir inclus dedans
parce qu'à d'autres sites qu'ils le font
et je trouve que bon ça fait un peu cher
pour ce que c'est mais quand même tout
un tas d'effets et ils ont l'avantagé
d'être aussi classés par type d'effet on
a des mouches on a des mouvements de
foule on a plein de trucs comme ça quand
même assez pratique pour aller trouver
rapidement des sont là ou sur d'autres
sites moi je sais que pour trouver des
sons fallait que je traduise en anglais
que voilà c'était un peu galère pour au
final j'arrive à retrouver mais sont
beaucoup plus rapidement sur arte liste
même si encore une fois je dis c'est pas
non plus le truc le plus indispensable
de la terre on peut trouver des choses
en gratuit sur internet là on va dire
que c'est une solution de feignants
quand on veut vraiment le truc sans
avoir à se prendre la tête
autre petit truc sympa c'est qu'on peut
aussi aller voir des artistes en
particulier moi je sais que y'a des fois
j'aime vraiment un artiste et je sais
que toutes ces chansons sont un petit
peu dans le même genre donc généralement
le cenou n'ont repéré quelques artistes
et puis je fais mes courses je
télécharge leur musique et je me dit de
toute façon ça va me servir c'est quand
même plutôt cool et on en arrive au
point
hyper hyper hyper intéressant pour les
gens comme moi qui sont free lance qui
font du youtube
ok mais qui font aussi des prestations
pour des clients le gros problème qu'on
peut rencontrer quand on utilise de la
musique pour des clients que ce soit sur
n'importe quelle plateforme c'est la
licence parce que sur d'autres plates
formes concurrentes c'est très bien
pouvez télécharger vos musiques les
lisez sur votre chaîne youtube et tout
mais si cette musique elle se retrouve
dans une vidéo qu'un client publie lui
sur sa chaîne par exemple sur son site
eh ben ça marche pas ça marche pas
pourquoi parce que la licence ne couvre
pas l'usagé commercial la licence dans
la plupart des autres sites
elle couvre uniquement lusage sur une
plate-forme en l'occurrence souvent
youtube et votre chaîne uniquement le
reste du temps vous vous prenez un
strike monumentale dans la gueule et sur
arte liste c'est là que tout change
la licence elle est globale c'est à dire
qu'à partir du moment où vous avez votre
abonnement à partir du moment où vous
avez téléchargé la musique pouvez même
télécharger un petit certificat de
licence qui dit que vous avez le droit
d'utiliser cette musique là vous pouvez
utiliser pour absolument tout ce que
vous voulez n'importe quel réseau social
votre client la licence commerciale
elle est incluse donc y'a pas de soucis
de droits là dessus les licences c'est
souvent un gros casse-tête en terme de
musique quand on travaille dans la vidéo
est là vraiment tout est hyper simple il
ya une licence qui est universel qui
sert à tout et vous voulez l'utiliser
pour n'importe quoi sachant que même si
vous avez téléchargé une musique que
vous n'avez pas utilisé que votre
abonnement se termine et que vous
utilisez cette musique après eh ben vous
avez encore la licence pas comme sur
d'autres sites ou si vous utilisez une
musique et si vous publiez une vidéo
après votre dada bonnement boom un
strike dans la gueule là à partir du
moment où c'est télécharger c'est bon
pour toujours et ça c'est quand même le
gros gros plus c'est encore une fois si
vous êtes free lance un truc qui est
hyper cool quand vous avez un client qui
sait pas trop ce qu'il veut comme
musique mais qui a quand même envie de
la choisir et de tout simplement vous
dites à votre client je vous envoie le
lien du site que j'utilise pour les
musiques vous pouvez écouter tout le
catalogue choisir une musique vous me
dites quel titre
moi je la récupère et je l'intègre à
votre montage et là il n'y a plus de
problème de choix de musique c'est juste
parfait
vous avez de l'argent fait des caisses
mais vraiment j'ai testé toutes les
autres plateformes et vraiment ça fait
deux ans un peu plus que je suis sur
celle là que jean bougerait pour rien au
monde
parce que cette licence - elle me sauve
donc c'est le petit conseil que je donne
si vous voulez vous abonner à un service
de musique payant dont vidéo
moi je vous recommande d'aller sur arte
liste si bien sûr vous avez une activité
diverses il vous fait que de youtube
à la limite on s'en fou n'importe quelle
plateforme
fera la sphère du moment que les
musiques vous plaisent mais il y aura
pas ce souci-là si vous avez d'autres
activités comme les activités de vendre
des vidéos là de suite ça peut être
hyper intéressant et je pense même que
c'est la plateforme la plus intéressant
au passage si ça vous intéresse il ya un
petit lien affilié dans la description
donc si vous vous abonnez par le biais
de ce lien et bien vous gagnez deux mois
supplémentaires d'utilisation pour arc
liste et moi je prends une petite
commission au passage je vous pousse pas
à la consommation c'est vraiment si vous
en avez besoin
ce lien il est là depuis deux ans je
crois donc n'hésitez pas si vous voulez
vous abonner et bénéficier de deux mois
supplémentaires à votre abonnement passé
plutôt par ce lien en plus ça soutient
la chaîne et tout donc c'est cool et si
tout ça vous a semblé utile et si tout
ça vous a plu vous pouvez mettre le
traditionnel coup de blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui se situe juste en
dessous de cette vidéo va regarder
d'autres vidéos de la chaîne on parle de
plein de choses qui peuvent vous
intéresser moi je vous dis en attendant
mes amis rester curieux et à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
[Musique]